would you consider yourself Progressive
I I want to see progress
so in that sense but by the dictionary
definition I guess so the problem is
that there might be you might have some
ideas about what is implied by the
political term Progressive that maybe I
agree with maybe I don't but I
definitely want to see you know Humanity
progress and one of the reasons I'm
concerned about you being a progressive
is that me specifically or all
progressives all men men only men only
men Progressive women don't concern it's
normal normal abnormal for women to be
Progressive interesting oh a liberal but
it's abnormal for a man to be a liberal
or Progressive is a sign of being a beta
male I didn't know they call real men
are Conservative Republican you know and
strong in future so I'm concerned if
you're a liberal or Progressive if I
became conservative would I no longer be
beta you would become Alpha well
something to think about yeah